نقول لك اولا ما نشر حول هذه القضيه
والقول بان القوى المحافظه والاشاره واضحه
اليكم سيد حلمي بانها منعت احمد سالم او
المطرب النقاش من الغناء على مسرح الاوبرا
بحجه عدم استكمال اوراق وايضا بدعي
بريستيج الاوبرا افتردون
احب اقول حاجه انا اول من استمع الى احمد
سالم وعجبت بصورته وحسيت ان في طعم جديد
في حياتنا بعد فوضى اغاني المهرجان قلت ده
هيكون بدايه جميله جدا ان احنا نرجع
لقصرنا الغنائيه خلاص بعد كده في اللجنه
التحضريه حطينا برامج اللي هي اعلن عنها
طول البرنامج وللاسف كان نفسي الاعلام
يتكلم عن عن المهرجان من اوله لاخره مش عن
حاجه
احب اقول
ان لما اتحط اصاله لم تعلن اصاله ناسا
وبدو تشرق
الاستاذ احمد سالم
اداره المهرجان ما كانش عندها علم فجاه
اداره المرجان لاقيت بيتعمل بروفا فطلبت
منه بعض اوراق ويجي يقابل على اساس يسجل
ويبقى ليه مكان داخل الاوبرا راح اختفى ما
جاش ثم
اصاله حصل حوار ما بينها وما بين الاداره
المهرجان ان كذا طب اخبرينا طب قولي لنا
طب احنا قلنا له تعالى طب كل شيء قالت
طبعا ما هتصرف هذا التصرف نتج عنه انه ما
طلعش مش من اداره المهرجان ولكن صاحب
التصرف هو فضل انه يبتعد عن المشاكل او
انه اعتقد ان هناك في مشاكل فلم يحضر الحب
الموسيقى العربيه
لماذا منع من ذلك
لم يمنع حد ولكن اداره الاوبرا يجب ان
يكون عندها علم ان مش حفل عامله متعايد
حفلات ده حفله اكاديميه بتعملها فلازم
اداره المهرجان تتعرف لان كان في سباق قبل
كده وطلع انسان قدم اعمال كان 30 كلم لما
كلم سيدنا الوزيره قلت لها مين واقف على
ان ده يقوم بالاعمال دي لانك عباره عن
مهزله موسيقيه فكان على الاقل اداره
المهرجان يبقى عندها علم مين جاي يغني ما
كانش عندهم علم الا فجاه اتعمل بروفه وبعد
كده رغم هذا قالوا له طب ابقى تعالى يوم
كذا عشان عايزينك كذا ما جاءش ان فيه
الحفله هتتعمل وهم ما يعرفوش مين اللي
طالع يغني انما حلمي بكر ما لوش دخل لان
احد المعجبين بصوته يبقى ازاي حمعه ولكن
الاداره لها بروتوكول هي حره فيه مش انا
مين الاخرى اسمي عشان يتقال ان انا قلت ما
يغنيش
طيب يعني اتهامات الطبقيه
والنظره الاستعلائيه التي وجهت المهرجان
غير صحيحه
وبذوق العلمي ما حدث لصالح احمد سالم هذا
اللقط وهذه الاثاره هتمهدوا بان الجمهور
يلتفت اليويو ويبقى له كيان يبقى اذا دي
اصبحت احد الاساليب الفرقعه اللي ممكن
تمهد للمطرب انه يغني وينجح اذا قدم
الاعمال اللي هو احمد
طب وايه اللي يمنع ان يكون ليه توفر في
نظام اداري
ده فيه نظام للاوبرا يجب ان يتابع اذا كان
احد المطربين الكبار لم يتبع نظام منع من
الحفله مش هاقول اسمه من اكبر مطربين ليه
لان في بروتوكولات في الاوبرا لازم ان
تنفذ اينما بكر
انها حادثه بمطرب عايزه تقدمه ويبقى اضافه
لفقرتها انما لما الدوله
اروح داخل مغني تحت مساله مين
اللي حصل تجربه قبل كده ومش هاقول اسم مين
اللي كان سبب وكانت الدنيا مقلوبه طب لسه
دي ولا ايه
تمام شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره الموسيقار
الكبير حلمي بكر شكرا جزيلا